so ansonsten genießen wir gemeinsam die
kurze pause zwischen bahnstreik 3 und
bahn streikt vier ja langsam gewöhnt man
sich dran was tragisch ist denn
eigentlich müsste man ja fürs klima viel
mehr deutsche auf die schiene locken wir
brauchen mehr junge nachwuchskräfte die
bock haben auf bahn und wenn sie könnten
würden sie sich welche position
auswählen lokführer
tja warum nicht kannst du doch bald
machen wir schaffen an dass über die
hälfte der deutschen hat kein
verständnis mehr für den warnstreik und
das kann man natürlich auch verstehen
die leute sauer sind zum ferienende
gestreikt wird fair wäre als beispiel
wenn gewerkschaften vorher mal so
fragebögen an jeden haushalt schicken
würden wo ich dann ankreuzen kann wann
mit der streik am besten passt als
anregung das nächste mal immerhin hat
die bahn sich redlich bemüht die
schlimmsten streik folgen aufzufangen
die haben wussten sie dass zum beispiel
den wütenden bahnkunden 9000 leih
fahrräder zur verfügung gestellt so voll
nett allzu weit weg von ihrer
arbeitsstelle sollten die indes nicht
wohnen denn wirklich kostenlos ist das
angebot nur während der ersten 30
minuten hey ein fahrrad von der
deutschen bahn kostenlos für 30 minuten
ja was gibt es da zu motzen das ist so
eine super alternative zum beispiel wenn
man jeden tag geschäftlich von köln nach
frankfurt pendelt jeden fall gut für den
kreislauf und wenn der flieger nach
mallorca ausfällt verteilen sich
schwimmflügel wenig überraschend
wirklich wenig überraschend richtet sich
der volkszorn seit wochen vor allem
gegen einen mann gegen claus weselsky
den gdl boss diesen fleischgewordenen
ersatzfahrplan dabei ist der mann wenn
man ihm zuhört doch sowas wie
deutschlands letzter echter
arbeiterführer die tricksen und täuschen
wie wild gewordene nieten in
nadelstreifen keine verantwortung
wahrnehmen und viel geld verdienen im
campus porten klare kante zeigen nicht
die butter vom brot nehmen lassen und
dann ist jedes mittel recht gehört zu
denen die wenn sie auf die linke wange
einige knallt kriegen die rechte auch
hinhalten da gibt es zurück eben auf die
fresse mit anlauf claus weselsky will
mit seiner gdl neben lokführern und
zugbegleitern auch beschäftigte in
werkstätten und bahnhöfen vertreten das
ist muss wir dazu sagen bei ihm aber
auch zum teil genetisch bedingt er hat
tatsächlich schon als fötus acht tage
den geburtskanal seiner mutter blockiert
weil er auch alle anderen eizellen
vertreten wollte aber wissen sie auf wen
sie als bahnkunde auch sauer sein dürfen
auf die groko
2015 hat die groko nehme ich das so
genannte tarif einheits gesetz
beschlossen seitdem gilt gibt es nach
einem betrieben mehr als eine
gewerkschaft gilt der tarifvertrag den
die mit den meisten mitgliedern
ausgehandelt hat genau das bedroht aber
die existenz von klein gewerkschaften
wie der gdl wovor experten von anfang an
gewarnt haben man wollte weniger streiks
und hat jetzt mehr und mal ganz ehrlich
unter uns eigentlich tief drin wollen
wir doch alle so einen harten hund der
für uns kämpft die heute show vermietet
ab sofort schlechte weselsky googles für
ihre alltags bedürfnisse
kannst du den müll runterbringen
der kollege hat im februar und april
diesen jahres bereits zwei mal den müll
runtergebracht der ist am limit während
die feine dame vom haushaltsvorstand
sich die taschen vollmacht und in
prosecco bordet keinen finger rühren wir
nicht gibt's nicht mal mehr sex
schnauze ich regle das hier
deine gdl
mehr weselsky wagen sage ich seit jahren
ok heißt es dann streikrecht gut und
schön aber doch nicht mitten in arona
krise bei einem konzern mit mehr als 30
milliarden schulden
dabei haben die schulden der machen
wenig mit corona zu tun die hat sich ein
unfähiger bahnvorstand über jahre hat er
arbeitet unter anderem durch
verlustreiche auslandsbeteiligung den
größten umsatz machte die deutsche bahn
mit sachen die nichts mit bahnfahren in
deutschland zu tun haben unter anderem
betreiben die eine der größten lkw
flotten europas erzählen aber der gdl
der streik werden anschlag aufs klima
ist klar was ich damit sagen will wer
denkt an der jetzigen misere sei nur die
lokführer schuld der hat zähne mehr alle
meine liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
genau kiga fakt am rande die deutsche
bahn kriegt es peinlicher weise auch
nicht hin 3g in ihren zügen zu
kontrollieren wer nicht leistbar
politisch verantwortlich dafür ist
dieser mann an die scheuer als
verkehrsminister wohl nur noch ein paar
wochen im amt zumindest wenn es einen
gott gibt was wird bleiben vom an die
was ist sein vermächtnis im amt aber die
menge für bayern und für die region
niederbayern herausgeholt es gibt wohl
kaum ein verkehrsminister so viel geld
nach bayern gelingt hat die anti steuer
toll und nur dafür hat man ja ein
bundesverkehrsminister damit mehr geld
nach bayern kommen ist ja logisch ich
sage ihnen das jetzt ganz ehrlich ich
persönlich gerade für uns von der heute
show wird sein abschied demnächst eine
sehr emotionale sache herzlich
willkommen zu
das große heute show an die shoah quiz
als dankeschön für über 9.000
sendeminuten
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer in wenigen wochen ist er
früheren einer der vielleicht 34 500
besten verkehrsminister die deutschland
je hatte ande scheuer und sein größter
fan der oliver ist heute abend unser
kandidat hallo oliver hallo ich weiß
alles über an die steuer wirklich es
gibt so viele faszinierende fakten über
den man was viele ja nicht wissen er hat
mal lehramt für realschule studiert und
seinen lieblingssport ist basketball wow
das interessiert ja wirklich keine sau
oliver erste frage deutschland arbeitet
seit sechs jahren an einem digitalen zug
steuerungssystem wie vier prozent
unseres schienennetzes sind bis heute
digitalisiert
ich schätze mal so die hälfte 50 prozent
ganz ganz genau daneben oliver wirklich
ganz ganz knapp es ist ein prozent
gerade mal 340 kilometer wir sind solche
looser
39 prozent der deutschen gleise sind
noch nicht mal elektrifiziert die warten
noch auf das wunder des stroms da
bleiben viele fragen zum beispiel haben
sie schon mal sich für andreas scheuer
geschämt
nein sagt der markus- und diese antwort
war falsch so nächste frage die maut die
pkw-maut ruhig junge ganz ruhig bitte
meisten fragen abwarten ja deutschland
ist an mehreren europäischen bahn
projekten beteiligt hier zum beispiel an
der güterverkehr straße von italien nach
holland österreich und italien bauen
dafür einen gewaltigen tunnel durch die
alpen sind sogar im zeitplan der brenner
basistunnel soll 2027 fertig sein die
gleise in deutschland wird es frühestens
2038 geben
gleiche blamage bei der
alpentransversale die schweiz ist damit
ihrem teil der arbeiten seit dezember
2020 fertig wir schaffen es wohl erst
bis
2041 frage was kann deutschland
überhaupt noch auf der schiene
das weiß ich nicht oliver es ist so
einfach wir sind auch lärmschutz
europameister ich sage sogar lärmschutz
weltmeister
lärmschutz weltmeister bei kaum züge
fahren das ist mein humor oder
so kommentiert zur final frage
aufgepasst oliver letzte frage was sagt
scheuer wenn er nach seinen
zukunftsplänen gefragt wird
wahrscheinlich sorry wegen allem meinem
nachfolger viel glück
komplett falsch an die scheuer sagte im
juli der dpa er würde gerne minister
bleiben zitat mir macht es viel freude
ich habe noch viel vor ach du scheiße
jaggi der oliver ach du scheiße und
nächste woche dann unser abschieds quiz
für julia klöckner erster frage wo
arbeitet sie ab oktober bei nestlé oder
doch beides super spannend
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]